this kind of loyalty
is referring to uh a connection with
something outside of yourself
yeah um so i i think you've spoken about
like existentialism or even just atheism
in general as um
as leading naturally to an individualism
as a focus on the
on the self and the ideas
that maybe the christian faith can um
instill in you is um allowing you to
sort of look outside of yourself so
connection i mean
loyalty fundamentally is about other
beings
and yeah other beings and i mean i think
i don't know what it is in me but i'm
very much drawn to that idea
and um i think humans in general are
drawn to that idea
you can you can make all kinds of
evolutionary arguments all that kind of
stuff but
uh people always kind of tease me uh
because i talk about love a lot and i
mean there's a lot of uh
non-scientific things about love right
like what what the heck is that thing
why why do we even need that thing
it uh it seems to be an annoying burden
that uh that we
we get so much uh joy in in life from a
connection with other human beings deep
uh lasting connections with human beings
same thing with loyalty
why why do we get so much value and
pleasure
and strength and meaning from loyalty
from a connection with somebody else
going through thick and thin with
somebody else going through some hard
times any
some of the you know the closest friends
i i have is going through some
some rough times together and that seems
to make life
deeply meaningful what is that
so yeah um i that's
that resonates with me and i obviously i
would i would affirm it um
i think just to just to correct the
implication that you made i i don't
think it's
necessarily the co the consequence of
atheism
uh that we that we lose track of those
kinds of things
i i mean i think that atheists can be
loyal okay if you like
um the question more often
comes up in the context of you know
where does morality come from
and loyalty i think and duty are
related to one another you know if we
have loyalty to someone then we have a
duty to them
okay as well and i think that in so far
as we see ourselves as having some kinds
any kinds of duties or moral compulsions
with respect to our relationships to
other people
it's a i think it's a question that
always arises well where does this where
do these come from
and there there are various approaches
that people have towards
deciding what makes ethics or morality
moral okay but i do think it's the case
that um it's very hard
to ground morality um
in any kind of absolute way or a
persuasive way
um in mere human relationships
and so it's certainly the case that in
christianity
um there is a sense in which
um morality and
you know the morality of morals comes
from
a transcendent place from a transcendent
deity and that we um
that we ground
our the compelling force of
of morals on god uh more than we do
on individuals because after all you
know if it
if you if you've got nothing but you
know other people
why should you you know treat your
neighbor well
why shouldn't you defraud your neighbor
if it's good for you
well you know you can construct all
kinds of arguments and some of them are
you know obviously
arguments that are commonplace in
religion too you should do as
you would be done by and all this kind
of thing right but none of that
seems any any more than mere pragmatism
to most people
okay and so that's what that's one of
the things if
that nature amongst others you know
really identified you know if god is
dead if the idea of god is grounding our
moral behavior
is no longer viable in the west which
nietzsche thought that it wasn't
okay then what does ground it and and he
had no good answer for it
in fact he claimed there was no answer
but then he couldn't live with that
and so he invented the idea of the
ubermensch you know this the superior
human being
okay and this was uh a different way of
trying to
ground morality not a very successful
one you know you could argue that
is the forerunner of the sort of
racism of hitler's regime and and
and so forth um that you know we've
in the west thankfully shied away from
uh in the in the past uh
half or three quarters of a century but
um
you know i think it is the case that
uh christianity gives me a
basis for my moral beliefs
that is more than mere pragmatism
yeah but there is a so stepping outside
of all that
there does seem to be a powerful
stabilizing
like we humans are able to hold ideas
together
like in a distributed way outside of
whether god exists or not or any that
just
our ability to kind of converse together
towards a set of beliefs
uh into sometimes into tribes it's kind
of
um i don't know if it's inherent to
being
human beings and i hope not because now
if i look on twitter
uh and there's uh there's the red team
and the blue team
right it's almost like uh it's it's a
charac it's some kind of tv show that
we're living in
uh that people get into these tribes and
they hold a set of beliefs
that sometimes don't um i mean they
they are beliefs for the sake of holding
those beliefs and we get this
intimate connection between each other
for sharing those beliefs
and we spoke to the things about loyalty
and love and that's the thing that
people feel inside the tribe
and it seems very human that within that
tribe
those beliefs don't necessarily always
have to be connected to anything
it's just the fact that you know i've
did sports
my whole life whenever you're on a team
the bond you get
with other people on the team is
incredible and
the actual sport is is often the
silliest
i mean i don't play ball sports anymore
but the ball
when i played like soccer or tennis i
mean all those sports are silly
right you're playing with a little ball
but there's the bond you get
is so deeply meaningful so i just it's
interesting to me on the sociological
level that um
it's it's possible to me whatever the
beliefs of religion
is um whatever they're actually grounded
in
they might be uh they might have a power
in themselves
i think there is tribalism everywhere
and i think tribalism in the us at the
moment is
rather difficult to bear from my point
of view um
and it's i think fed by the internet and
social media and so forth but
but it's but historically tribalism is
has been a trait and remains a trait in
humans
the genius of christianity is
that it supersedes tribalism i mean
yes when the hebrews
thought about yahweh initially
they thought about him as their tribal
deity just like the tribal deities round
about
about them and so but and and yet
from you know early on
in hebrew history the crucial thing that
yahweh
came to mean or i would say revealed
of himself to them was that he wasn't
just a tribal deity he was the
god that created the whole thing and if
he is the god of the whole thing then
he's not just the god of
the hebrews or in the case of you know
uh americans god is not just the god of
americans he's the god of everybody
okay and that is a way
in a way the most amazing um
transcending of tribal loyalties
and uh one of the crucial you know
occasions
in the new testament um you know when
the holy spirit comes at pentecost
um you know the the the apostles and the
and the disciples speak in other tongues
and there are people from all
the countries you know round about hear
them
in their own languages and so you know
whether
whether you take that as factual or not
that is the a statement of the
transcendent
um aspects of christianity or the
claimed
transcended aspects of christianity that
it transcends culture
and that's certainly something which i
find appealing
you